go into the next game as opposed that
they can what you did to put yourself
position to dominate on Friday night
shake Milton knocks down another Milton
five for five
[Applause]
shot clock at two
Milton launches a three knocks it down
Jake Milton six for seven from the field
Milton putting on a clinic extremely
comfortable just because Glenn Robinson
hasn't scored yet
you shouldn't knock him down a peg he's
the third not the super I mean it'd be
Skippy I know he's not start started
strong but comes right back
offensive van gets it going going to the
cup and then knocking down the long ball
he's feeling Leonard Harrell struggled
with holding on to it Harris picks it up
[Music]
Milton for three hang Jake Middleton
from downtown
Milton uses a Horford screen 3-pointer
got it again
Jake Milton a career-high 29 offending a
guy that's red-hot you can't go
underneath you have to stay connected
stop there should have been a charge on
Paul George
it's only a seven-point game I talking
about the six is just a piggyback with
coach Eric Milton for three from
downtown and it's down to four timeout
clippers defensive end where we can do
that every single night and off of the
great defense timely quality offense
shake built continuing to get it done
the contest too late for the heck of
afternoon for this young man
it's Borgia logic which I don't I don't
know Jake Milton max attend Milton again
7 for 8 from downtown it's at a game
that he'll never forget I'm gonna
celebrate his game this afternoon I'm
gonna have a shake